janni swarovskis hat im letzten sommer
ganz europa in aufregung versetzt also
den anderen euro- finanzministern die
stirn bot dieser brandstifter fackelt
das europäische haus noch abschalten die
einen nein er ist der letzte
fackelträger der es noch wagt gegen die
kalte machtpolitik der finanzmärkte
aufzubegehren priesen ihn die anderen
navarro fakt ist herzlich willkommen bei
uns im studio und herzlich willkommen
auch liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
navarro fakt ist dass sie gerne eigene
wege gehen das ist so bemessen
weltbekannt das taten sie offenbar schon
damals als student wohnt
wer möchte nicht in der lage sein eine
position zu vertreten die mit den
eigenen prinzipien übereinstimmt und
gleichzeitig mit all jenen im dialog
stehen die sich dem wunderbaren
unterfangen der menschlichen existenz
verschrieben haben
aber erzählen sie uns ich konnte es fast
nicht glauben als ich irgendwo gelesen
habe als student in england an der
universität essex waren sie da sprecher
oder sekretär der schwarzen
studentenschaft sie sehen für mich nicht
so schwarz aus genau darum ging es
ich stand vorne zum beispiel an einer
großen gewerkschafts konferenz- und
begannen eine rede mit den worten wir
schwarzen studenten natürlich haben alle
gedacht
das gehörte zum ablauf mein nächster
satz war dann mal schwarz ist eine
geisteshaltung die nichts zu tun hat mit
der dna oder die hautfarbe es ist eine
soziale kategorie
und wenn es eine geisteshaltung ist
sollten wir besser damit anfangen anders
zu denken über rasse geschlecht soziale
klassen und all die dinge die uns
trennen stadt vereint das war der grund
weshalb die schwarze
studentenvereinigung mich fragte ob ich
ihr sprecher sein wolle
und weshalb ich die einladung gerne
angenommen habe
und wenn sie von mir noch eine weitere
rechtfertigung wollen wir griechen iren
und eine reihe anderer leute sind die
schwarzen europas da kann man dazu sagen
dass sie auch aus einer familie kommen
die nicht gerade immer rebellisch war
aber wo die menschen ihre standpunkte
überzeugt vertreten haben
ihr vater war unter der diktatur dieser
obristen dieser rechten generäle drei
jahre im lager ich komme aus einer
familie von liberalen demokraten
wenn sie oder unsere zuschauer in einer
neofaschistischen diktatur leben würden
wie das bei uns in den 1960 er jahren
der fall war
deren auch wenn man ihnen verbieten
würde musik zu hören bücher zu lesen
wenn sie keine deutsche welle werden
durften
ich glaube man hat er eine moralische
pflicht zu rebellieren und meine familie
rebellierte unsere besten helfer in
dieser region waren die menschen in
deutschland österreich der schweiz und
in frankreich
zum glück war diese schreckliche
diktatur einige jahre später vorbei dank
die rebellion von guten mensch ihr onkel
auch mal im gefängnis war sogar zum tode
verurteilt worden er hatte allerdings
eine bombe gebastelt oder sowas
mein onkel der bruder meiner mutter war
geschäftsführer von siemens in
griechenland
er war ein rechter mein vater und er
hatten immer sehr heftige
auseinandersetzungen
er war bei den neoliberalen in
griechenland unterstützte die freien
demokraten die fdp in deutschland weil
er enge verbindungen zu deutschland
hatte mein vater wurde kommunist weil
man ihn ins gefängnis warf da er sich
weigerte eine deklaration zu
unterschreiben die den kommunismus
verurteilte ihn sagte zu den polizisten
das war in den 40er jahren
ich bin kein gut ist aber wenn ihr von
mir verlangt dass ich eine erklärung
unterschreibe die den buddhismus
verurteilt werde ich es nicht tue weil
der staat nicht die macht haben soll der
einzelne menschen seine bürger zu
solchen distanzierungen zu zwingen
worauf sie ihn in ein
konzentrationslager sperrten zusammen
mit kommunisten und mein vater schloss
sich ihnen an
aber zurück zu meinem onkel 1967 als
sein politisches lager also die rechten
eine militärdiktatur unterstützten so
hat er es mir gegenüber einmal
dargestellt haben eher so wie viele
andere bürgerliche liberale und mit
rechts weiter gegen das eigene lager
rebelliert und sich von staatsstreich
und militär diktatur distanziert
sie bildeten eine organisationen eine
widerstandsgruppe die bomben legte um
ihre opposition gegen die
militärdiktatur öffentlich zu machen
sie planten sehr sorgfältig um niemanden
zu verletzen
und es wurde auch niemand verletzt das
war ihre art widerstand zu leisten gegen
die militärdiktatur
diese organisationen die sich
demokratische verteidigung nannte würde
in der erinnerung zu einer wichtigen
widerstandsgruppe gegen die
militärdiktatur assistance gruppe
gangster kritisch und sie haben offenbar
als bot der einmal gedient um irgendeine
nachricht aus dem gefängnis heraus zu
tragen was war da geschehen gehörte
damals zum alltag
es gab eine zeit da besuchte ich meinen
onkel im avw gefängnis in athen
für mich als kleinen jungen war es
einfacher botschaften hinein und hinaus
zu schneiden nur nachrichten von der
familie und von freunden nichts dass
verschwörerische oder heroischer gewesen
wäre
aber es war aufregend für einen jungen
ich erinnere mich an eine situation als
mein onkel in der gefängniszelle das
modell eines stock eines deutschen
kampfflugzeugs nachgebaut hatte
weil ich kampfflugzeuge liebte das acht-
oder zehnjährigen damals und demmin an
befand sich eine kleine botschaft an
seine frau war das sind die erinnerungen
an sehr turbulente zeit
aber das gedächtnis das oft ein wenig
beschleunigt erlaubt einem immer auf
paradoxe art diese schrecklichen zeiten
rückblickend als wunderbar zu sehen
paradox gateways klar eine gute zeit war
es nicht für das land der westen hat
auch zugeschaut dass da eine diktatur
eine militär unter von 67 bis 74 ist
dieses europäische land regieren konnte
und sie da aber als junger romantischer
kinder revolutionär gestartet und sie
haben erwähnt die deutsche welle das
fand ich auch interessant das
griechische drama dieses sommers an das
wir uns alle hier in europa erinnern da
zwei protagonisten eigentlich den
deutschen schäuble wolfgang schäuble und
den griechen yannis varro [ __ ] is die
zwei gegenseitige gegensätzliche welten
vertreten
da fand ich es interessant als ich
gelesen habe dass die deutsche welle
deutschland war damals in der zeit der
diktatur für sie ein ideal sie haben das
gehörte heimlich mussten die deutsche
welle hören nicht nur wie er damals
hörten die meisten demokratien in
griechen haid entweder bbc oder deutsche
welle die deutsche welle hatte soweit
ich mich erinnere das bessere programm
es war viel informativer und
unterstützte den griechischen
demokratischen widerstand gegen die
diktatur viel stärker ich wuchs in einem
griechenland auf indem deutschland als
überragendes beispiel eines großartigen
demokratischen landes galt
deutschland gehörte zu den wichtigsten
verbündeten von uns allen
wie in griechenland dafür kämpften unser
land in die europäische gemeinschaft
einzugliedern griechenland zu
demokratisieren und aus dem dunklen
zeitalter von diktatur rückständigkeit
und vormoderne hinaus zu führen
aber in diesen dunklen zeiten konnten
sie deutsche welle nicht offiziell hören
das musste man leise tun war illegal in
der tat versuchte das regime die
frequenzen der deutschen welle zu
sperren
mein vater musste in ein sehr gutes
kurzwellenradio investieren um die
versuche der diktatur das programm
abzublocken zu unterlaufen
denn wir hatten einen nachbarn der
schnüffelte und versuchte sich beim
geheimdienst einzuschmeicheln in dem er
über meine familie berichtete meine
familie war ja wie bereits erwähnt
bekannt dafür dass sie gegen das regime
war und sie suchten nach vorwänden um
uns zu verfolgen
dann machen wir einen großen sprung
schon mal kurz in die zeit wo sie dann
minister ihres landes sind und dieses
rebellische immer noch in sich zu haben
scheinen und den hang würde ich mal
sagen zur provokation
auch die aber dieses foto mitgebracht wo
sie dann zum ersten mal zum englischen
minister aus bonn gehen
downing street eleven grad neben der
downing street and premierminister amt
und der gute mann kollege ausbauen hat
sich so eine mühe gegeben den schönsten
blauen anzug die schönste blaue krawatte
und sie kommen da ein lederband wollten
sie die leute provozieren hallo hier
kommt der rebellen es war nie meine
absicht irgendjemanden zu provozieren
sie tragen auch keine krawatten
provozieren sie ihr ich glaubte immer
der inhalt zählt und nicht die
verpackung was diese spezielle situation
anbelangt nur
mit sie es wissen ich befürchte die
geschichte hinter dieser lederjacke ist
weniger heldenhaft als es scheint ich
war auf dem weg nach paris
und mein gepäck ging im transit verloren
ich musste mir einen mantel ausleihen
weil es sehr kalt war darunter trage ich
genau das ist jemand wie ich mir von
griechischen botschafter in frankreich
ich hatte mir dabei nichts gedacht nie
werde ich auf die idee gekommen damit
anstoß zu erregen das war nicht gewollt
aber wissen sie was im endeffekt bin ich
froh dass man es als fehltritt
beurteilte machen wir uns nichts vor die
besten anzüge und krawatten werden von
der mafia in new york getragen ich würde
nicht behaupten dass sie das zu guten
oder vertrauenswürdigen mitgliedern der
gesellschaft macht auch nicht umgekehrt
jeder guten müssten wir uns in europa
nicht auf inhalte konzentrieren
ich versichere ihnen dass alle
griechischen minister vor mir
finanzminister und andere die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass griechenland zu
einem gescheiterten und bankrotten staat
verkommen ist sehr schöne anzüge
getragen und niemanden provoziert haben
indem sie keine krawatten tragen müssten
wir uns nicht auf das konzentrieren
worauf es ankommt aber ist es nicht so
gerade wenn man ein erfahrener politiker
ist wie sie und auch riess hat es
eigentlich gesagt in seiner rhetorik sie
kennen die alten griechen ja auch gut
es gibt den logos das was man sagt aber
es gibt da auch den ethos wie man
positioniert ist und es gibt das
partners wie man direkt und man muss
darauf achten wie man wirkt jeder ansatz
den logos von pathos trennt die
wirtschaft von der politik
die logik von der ethik führt zur
schwächung menschlicher erfahrung wenn
logos der verbindung mit pathos beraubt
wird verliert es an bedeutung
macht und nutzen für die menschheit
genauso wie eine wirtschaft die von
politischen prozess getrennt wird den
wohlstand und erhöht und wie die
vernunft zutiefst irrational wird wenn
man sie von der ethik abspannen sind
okay ich bin schlecht platziert hierfür
die krawatte zu werben da haben sie
recht aber ich habe mir trotzdem
überlegen wenn es der sache gedient
hätte wären sie nicht auch bereit
gewesen konzessionen zu machen im look
sie haben die kollegen dann in brüssel
ja noch genug von anfang an stellte ich
klar
in dem moment wo wir mit der troika der
euro-gruppe den europäischen partnern
und dem iwf ein gutes abkommen haben im
moment wo wir uns darauf einigen die
griechischen schulden zu restrukturieren
und zu straffen und griechenland eine
echte reformagenda erhält werde ich eine
krawatte umgehen das sagte ich gleich am
anfang
wir haben nie eine entsprechende
vereinbarung erhalten deshalb trage ich
immer noch keine krawatte dann war
dieses drama dass europa sehr bewegt hat
auch so spannend von außen gesehen weil
wirklich sehr verschiedene positionen
aufeinander tragen
zuvor waren radikale gegenposition
marxistische zumal an den universitäten
in den büchern
und jetzt ist ein radikaler marx ist
plötzlich minister ist in zentrum der
macht und und redet und vertritt dort
seine thesen
bevor wir das im detail anschauen was da
passiert ist möchte ich sie fragen nach
ihrem menschenbild und ihrem bild des
kapitalismus aufgrund eines buches das
sie geschrieben haben mit dem titel wie
ich meiner tochter die wirtschaft
erkläre weil das ist es nicht so max ist
es trocken sondern sie sagen das wie man
sie einem teenager sagen könnte was sie
an der heutigen wirtschaft am system des
kapitalismus unmenschlich finden und sie
erzählen das eigentlich sehr schön am
beispiel von kapitän kostet das
den sie in dieser keinen parabel
zusammen mit ihrer tochter am abend in
einer taverne treffen was passiert
zwischen kapitän costas unter tochter
die geschichte ist sehr einfach
der kapitän bat meine tochter ihm zu
helfen den anker seines bootes zu heben
die auf dem meeresgrund festklemmt meine
tochter war sehr begeistert sie fühlte
sich nützlich geliebt sie hatte eine
aufgabe für die nächste stunde und bot
an zu tauchen und ein seil am verlorenen
anker festzumachen um kapitän costas zu
helfen ihn zurückziehe
ich erkläre mit dieser parabel übrigens
eine wahre geschichte den unterschied
zwischen preis und wert zwischen
tauschwert und lebenswert ich sagte zu
ihr stell dir vor stadt dir zu sagen
zehn jahre hilf mir das zu tun hätte er
gesagt ich gebe dir zehn euro wenn du es
machst hat vielleicht hätte dir die
vorstellung nass zu werden es ist abend
du musst ein nachtessen unterbrechen
das hätte sich nicht gelohnt für 10 euro
die art und weise hingegen wie er dich
eingeladen hat mit ihm eine
lebenserfahrung zu teilen war viel
verlockender
erinnern sie sich daran was oskar wald
gesagt hat ein zyniker ist ein mensch
der von jedem ding den preis und von
keinem den wert kennt zwischen wirten
und preisen zu unterscheiden ist sehr
wichtig nicht nur für das verständnis
von zwischenmenschlichen beziehungen
sondern auch um zu verstehen wie die
wirtschaft funktioniert
speziell die mechanismen weshalb märkte
und markt gesellschaften es oft nicht
schaffen aus den leuten das beste
herauszuholen weil sie den preis zu
stark gewichten ihr hauptvorwurf von den
kapitalismus dass er diese menschliche
seite verdrängt das alles tausch ist am
schluss mit einem preis etikett drauf
ich bin ein liberaler mehr als das ich
an max ist bin der marxismus ist wichtig
weil er mir hilft den kapitalismus zu
verstehen die welt in der wir leben
die wichtigste war für mich das
wichtigste prinzip ist jenes der
freiheit die schlimmste seite des
kapitalismus und der kapitalismus hat
auch wunderbare sagen wie die tatsache
dass er uns von feudalen abhängigkeiten
befreit hat usw
aber da sie mich nach meinem kritikpunkt
fragen die innovationskraft kommt durch
die freisetzung von kreativen
produktiven und innovativen kräften ist
einer der großen beiträge des
kapitalismus darüber gibt es keinen
zweifel
aber gleichzeitig das ist die dunkle
seite wenn sie so wollen ist das eine
dialektische hygienische sichtweise die
kehrseite ist das dauernde übergriffe
von preis von wert und von ökonomischen
dimensionen in den sozialen und
politischen bereich die menschen im
endeffekt versklaven
unabhängig davon ob sie besitzer von
unternehmen sind oder arbeiter die
arbeiten werden von den produkten ihrer
arbeitskraft entfremdet wie marx sagen
würde
sie werden mechanisiert so weit dass ihr
leben schließlich hoch repetitiv wird
ohne viel inhalt und ohne
existenzialistische beziehung zum
produkt ihrer arbeit wenn sie nach hause
gehen sind sie erschöpft sie sind voller
sorge wie sie sich über wasser halten
sie schauen dumme tv programme nicht
ihres in manchester wo die leute machen
waren also heute lebt er weiter der
arbeitnehmer recht gut auf den wenigen
griechenland aber in den
nordeuropäischen gesellschaften sind sie
sicher
in deutschland ist der prozentsatz der
working poor heute höher als vor 20
jahren
in deutschland für die schweiz gilt das
vielleicht nicht gibt es millionen von
menschen mit minijobs die unfreiwillig
nur wenige stunden pro woche arbeiten
für die es sehr schwierig ist sich über
wasser zu halten
sie leben in einem extrem reichen land
das sehr erfolgreich und sehr mächtig
ist trotzdem haben sie immer weniger
zugang zum wohlfahrtsstaat die qualität
ihres spitals nimmt ab die qualität der
ausbildung für ihre kinder geht zurück
und die qualität ihrer straßen ihre
häfen und der infrastruktur nimmt ab
während sie gleichzeitig hören wie ihre
regierung zb im bundestag dutzende
hunderte von milliarden an
rettungsgeldern genehmigt für
griechenland irland und so weiter und so
fort
das schafft große verwirrung aber zurück
zum kapitalistischen prozess diese
entfremdung betrifft nicht nur jene die
unter bedingungen von steigende
unsicherheit arbeiten auch ihre chefs
die kapitalisten die besitzer des
unternehmens sind ständig voller angst
vor geringer nachfrage nach ihren
produkten sie entfremden sich laufend
selber von ihrer eigenen arbeit ist es
denke diese unterteilung in jene die
besitzen aber sich keine gedanken machen
um die verteilung des einkommens und
jene die nicht besitzen aber arbeiten
diese unterteilung führt zu einer welt
die recht unzufrieden ist mit unseren
bedingungen
dies ist den john kenneth galbraith
gesellschaft im überfluss wie in torsten
lenz wie früherer theorie über die
feinen leute exzellent beschrieben wie
die kombination von kapitalismus und
konsumverhalten zu tiefe unzufriedenheit
führt je mehr wie unsere vorlieben
befriedigen wir alle verhalten uns wie
versuchstiere in einem hamsterrad wir
rennen immer schneller und schneller
aber kommen irgendwo hin
könnte man nicht aber ein bisschen
anpassen einen gedanken von churchill
den er über die demokratie gesagt habe
der kapitalismus ist das schlecht ist
das system von allen
abgesehen von allen anderen etwas
besseres
eine bessere alternative ist halt nicht
erfunden worden winston churchill hat
das über demokratie gesagt und ich bin
voll mit ihm einverstanden
über den kapitalismus hat er das nicht
gesagt und es wäre auch falsch gewesen
kapitalismus ist kein natürliches system
demokratie hingegen schon
es ist unbestritten dass der
kapitalismus eine wichtige kraft für den
fortschritt war jetzt aber hat er sich
überlegt darüber gibt es keinen zweifel
wir linken glaubten dass wir die linken
den übergang vom kapitalismus zu etwas
besserem bringen würden wir sind
gescheitert
aber ich glaube der kapitalismus
untergräbt sich selber sehr effizient
schauen sie sich die technologischen
innovationen an die der kapitalismus
hervorbringt wie zum beispiel den 3d
drucker das internet diese veränderungen
im bereich der technologie machen
unternehmen überflüssig
es kommt zu einem prozess der dies in
der mediation
warum sollte volkswagen general motors
oder sogar siemens weiterhin existieren
in einer zukunft die nähe der 3 d
drucker eine direkte beziehung zwischen
dem designer eines produkts und den
tatsächlichen produkt ermöglicht
wenn ich mich als marxist bezeichne ist
es nicht weil ich an eine kontinuität
von marx bis zu den marxistischen
bewegungen des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
glaube nein
marx größter beitrag zu meinem
verständnis der welt ist die erkenntnis
dass technologische innovation die
sozialen beziehungen zwischen den
menschen der stabilisiert wie auch die
art und weise wie wir dinge produzieren
und einkommen verteilt
dieser zusammenhang zerstörte den
feudalismus
ich bin überzeugt dass die heutigen
produkte des kapitalismus diesen
zerstören werden
was danach kommt ob es utopia sein wird
wie star trek wo alle herumsitzen
niemand arbeitet weil maschinen uns
alles abnehmen und wir sitzen herum und
führen philosophische diskussionen und
erforschen das universum
ob wir eine welt wie in star trek haben
werden oder er etwas in richtung dem
magix eine schreckensvisionen in der
sich maschinen die funktionen unserer
körper nutzbar gemacht haben und wir
vollständig zur beute des kapitals
geworden sind das wird von der
demokratie abhängen davon ob wir die
richtigen entscheidungen treffen um
sicherzustellen dass die produkte
unserer arbeit die maschinen das kapital
unseres sklaven sind oder ob wir von den
bedürfnissen des kapitals versklavt
werden verstehe die logik dieses
gedankengang müsste einer der sagt ich
bin aus diesen gründen marx ist nicht
gleichzeitig aber auch darüber
nachdenken jetzt schon wie man diese
schlimmen entwicklungen die ist dann
gegeben hat und dass darleen und in der
sowjetunion die freiheit dann weg war
wurde der start zu einem moloch wurde
das ist ja vielleicht auch angelegt
gewesen irgendwo in dieser theorie
müsste man nicht auch die anpacken
zettel beilegen warnung das kann ins
elend auch führen und das mache ich
durchmache das ständig vielleicht haben
sie bemerkt dass ich mich als libertären
marxistin zeichnet die meisten
kommentatoren fokussieren einzig auf den
marxisten und nicht auf das liebert er
für mich ist beides wird um das was sie
gesagt haben in der sprache von jemandem
zu formulieren der einmal hier in der
nähe von bern gewirkt hat den die
meisten unserer zuschauer kennen
erlauben sie mir mich auf friedrich von
hayek zu beziehen
von hayek hat sehr klug und
leidenschaftlich gesagt als kritik an
die linken und im speziellen an der
marxistischen linken dass die
sozialisten im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
zur verwirklichung des sozialismus
praktiken übernehmen müssten die
sozialisten eigentlich nicht
unterstützen könnten
und er hatte recht als linker trage ich
ständig die kollektive schuld des gulag
in mir
die kollekte gilt dieser abscheulichkeit
die im namen von marx von emanzipation
freyung sozialismus begangen wurde und
wir von der linken müssen dieses gefühl
der schuld dauernd aufrecht erhalten
konnten
das heißt aber nicht dass ich vor ihnen
die tatsache verstecke dass mein
verständnis des kapitalismus ohne marx
nicht wäre was es ist
es ist ein wenig wie ein christ der sich
nicht laufend für die spanische
inquisition entschuldigen muss bevor wir
darüber reden wollen was dann passiert
ist ganz konkret in dem moment wo dieser
libertäre max ist plötzlich in brüssel
erscheint wo die anderen anti marxisten
sitzen möchte ich noch einen moment über
jahr lang ihre heimat griechenland reden
eben dass die parabel hat mir sehr
gefallen oder sagt die menschlichen
werte sieht man dort wo der fisch das
junge mädchen bietet und auf diese insel
auch persönlich habe ich diese sympathie
für dieses land die wiege der demokratie
ging schon früh in jungen jahren hin und
haben aber etwas anderes auch über
dieses land auch schon sehr früh
erfahren meine erste reise interrail
ticket ist das und wir fahren da der
durch griechenland und bei meinem ersten
trip in griechenland wurde ich abgezockt
wie ich noch nie abgezockt worden war
ich habe ein bus genommen ich glaube von
patras nach irgendwo und da kommt
plötzlich mitten auf dem feld kommt ein
mann rein ein freund des chauffeurs sagt
haben sie die zusatzgebühr für ihren
rucksack bezahlt ich sage nein gibt es
das nimmt das geld und später steigt er
wieder aus da war ein freund des
bischofs der mich hier einfach
ausgenommen hat mit 16 jahren oder so
und viele denken jetzt in nördlichen
europäischen gegenden griechenland ist
auch das land wo gewisse eine gewisse
zivilität nicht hier ist also wo
wo strukturen sind das geht einfach
nicht das berühmte beispiel das auf
zakynthos ein namhafter teil der
bevölkerung als blind eingeschrieben ist
damit sie renten bekommen
wie sehen sie das ihre eigene heimat als
gesellschaft wo viel unehrlichkeit und
ein ziviles verhalten überlebt hat
dürfte ich einen vorschlag machen wird
dass wir verallgemeinerungen vermeiden
verallgemeinerung ist der anfang eines
prozesses wir uns auf einen äußerst
glitschigen abhang führt richtung ja
rassismus wenn sie irgendeine einzel
geschichte nehmen wie ihre schreckliche
erfahrung in meinem land und daraus
versuchen eine theorie abzuleiten
die griechen sind oder so ist
griechenland die natürliche reaktion
darauf ist dass die griechen eine
geschichte über die schweiz österreich
oder deutschland herausgreifen eine
nicht gerade erfreuliche und sagen die
schweizer die österreicher oder die
deutschen sind in dem moment wo sie
damit anfangen beginnt der prozess in
richtung europäischer des integration
wie wir ihn aktuell haben was äußerst
schädlich ist
nun ich finde durchaus gefallen daran
griechenland zu kritisieren meine kritik
ist bissiger und heftiger als ihre weil
ich viel häufiger an griechenland
gelitten haben als sie wir griechen sind
sehr gut im kritisieren von griechenland
wie die schweizer gut darin sind die
schweiz zu kritisieren und die deutschen
deutschland es ist wichtig diesen
prozess der schuldzuweisungen zu
vermeiden wenn sie eine diskussion
darüber wünschen was an den griechen
falsch ist können wir das aber der
moralisierende finger der von einem land
auf das andere gerichtet ist gehört
abgehakt okay wenn das den unterton
gehabt hätte er nicht beabsichtigt war
alle griechen sind aber es gab natürlich
bild schlagzeilen die faulen griechen
wollen unsere
renten gelder zu sich holen oder und so
aber dass der staat griechenland einfach
noch nicht so mit modernen im
akademischen sinne nationalen strukturen
schon organisiert da und funktionierte
das ist doch eine tatsache ein anderes
problem das zum teil war gar kein staat
und keine sie waren finanzminister waren
konnte gar keine steuern eintreiben
sie müssen verstehen dass der
entwicklungsstand eines staates der
staatlichen institutionen der grad der
rechtschaffenheit der bürokraten durch
das prisma die geschichte betrachtet und
erklärt werden muss
griechenland ist ein recht junger staat
es ist zwar eine sehr alte nation aber
ein eher junger staat
wer aus dem osmanischen reich heraus
entstanden ist in den ersten paar
jahrzehnten mehr als das in den ersten
jahrhunderten des griechischen staats
war es für arme griechen eine
patriotische pflicht keine steuern zu
bezahlen
sie erinnern sich im osmanischen reich
waren die steuern effektiv eine art
entzug von vermögen durch eine
besatzungsmacht
sehr bald nach der staatsgründung
übernahmen die gleichen
grossgrundbesitzer die schon unter den
osmanen das sagen hatten die führung in
griechischen staates absolut autoritär
eine weiterführung der osmanischen
herrschaft werden die armen bauern
betrachteten diese erneut als ihre
feinde
so entwickelte sich griechenland erst in
den 1920 er jahren zu einem modernen
staat
kurz darauf wurden wir in einer serie
von kriegen gestürzt
dazu gehörte der zweite weltkrieg und
der darauf folgende bürgerkrieg
wir sind also ein sehr junger starb mein
argument ist äußerst einfach um den
rechtsstaat und die institutionen zu
reformieren
sowie ein maß an ethik und anstand
wieder einzuführen sowohl im privaten
wie im öffentlichen sektor müssen wir
eine atmosphäre der hoffnung schaffen
wir brauchen wachstum wir brauchen
investitionen lassen sie es mich sehr
einfach formulieren
sie können ein unternehmen nicht
restrukturieren ohne zu investieren
sie können einen staat die bürokratie
nicht restrukturieren ohne zu
investieren
wegen des bankrotts des griechischen
staats haben wir in den letzten fünf bis
sechs jahren versucht zu reformieren
indem wir kürzen ohne neue strukturen
und institutionen zu investieren ohne
jene besser zu entlöhnen die fleißiger
waren was die anderen alle gehälter
wurden gekürzt
in einer gesellschaft in der jeder
zweite haushalts ohne lohn überlebt mit
irgendwelchen pensionsgelder eines
älteren familienmitglied ist es wichtig
dass wir griechenland herausholen aus
diesem milieu von fehlverhalten wie sie
es beschrieben haben
aber dafür müssen wir die hoffnung
schaffen
die einzig durch investitionen erzeugt
werden kann in deutschland zumal haben
dann viele ihre regierung der sie rieser
regierung vorgeworfen okay jetzt seid
ihr an die macht gekommen
und ihr habt auch nicht etwas
entschiedenes unternommen um steuern
endlich einzutreiben aber ich weiß da
wären sie sich vehement
es ist besser diese behauptung basiert
auf einem fundamentalen mangel an
informationen über das was zwischen
januar und juni geschehen ist ein
fundamentaler mangel an information
als ich nach berlin reiste um 1
gegenüber doktor schäuble zu treffen
als ich zur ersten sitzung der euro
gruppe ging präsentierte ich einen sehr
einfachen vorschlag
wir müssen griechenland reformieren wir
müssen unser steuersystem und die
verwaltung reformieren
wir müssen praktisch die gesamte
griechische volkswirtschaft reformieren
dafür brauchen wir aber eure hilfe nicht
geld das problem ist nicht dass
deutschland nicht genug bezahlt hätte
oder österreich ihr habt zu viel bezahlt
sagte ich zu ihnen
das haben sie minister schäuble direkt
gesagt oder der ganzen runde der
minister wo haben sie das zum ersten mal
klar gemacht am bilateralen treffen
das diesem bild voran ging an anderen
meetings in der euro gruppe
lassen sie mich einen der vorschläge der
doktor schäuble an diesem ersten treffen
gemacht habe verraten
ich sagte ihm eines meiner großen
probleme als finanzminister sei da war
ich erst seit zehn tagen finanzminister
dass sich die verwaltung meines
steuerbüros nicht traute ich wollte es
von grund auf umgestaltet
ich wollte so etwas wie den ahs in den
usa aufbauen
ein separates steuersystem außerhalb der
kontrolle meines ministeriums
ich wollte nicht dass politiker wie ich
die steuerbehörde überwachen aber auch
nicht dass es von privatunternehmen
kontrolliert wird ich wollte ein neues
steuersystem ein besseres reorganisierte
und unabhängiges steuersystem das sowohl
von politikern wie von
unternehmensinteressen unabhängig ist
und ich bat um hilfe
ich sagte wenn sie wirklich wollen dass
griechenland reformiert wird das muss
man nicht auf einem programm insistieren
dass gescheitert ist das wären fünf
jahren angewendet wurde und zu
katastrophalen einkommensverlusten
geführt hat dass in der griechischen
bevölkerung überhaupt keinen rückhalt
hat helfen sie uns das zu tun was die
griechische öffentlichkeit will die
griechen wollen ein unabhängiges
steuersystem dem alle vertrauen können
dafür erhielt ich keinerlei
unterstützung
ich sage ihnen genau was ihre antwort
war
ich werde nicht mit ihnen verhandeln
sprechen sie mit der troika troika also
diese instanz die die wahre macht die
internationale währungsfonds und die
europäische zentralbank und die
europäische kommission
ich sprach mit der troika ich legte
ihnen genau den gleichen vorschlag über
die notwendigkeit von reformen vor ich
sagte ihnen unter anderem in
griechenland haben wir sehr hohe
steuersätze und sehr tiefe
steuereinnahmen damit wir mehr steuern
einnehmen können müssen wir die
steuersätze senken und den griechischen
bürgern in anlehnung an rousseau einen
sozialvertrag anbieten wir senken den
steuersatz ihr bezahlt eure steuern
keine reaktion der iwf die europäische
kommission bestanden weiterhin darauf
dass wir die steuern erhöhen
man hatte also das eigenartige phänomen
das ich als linker für eine reduktion
der unternehmenssteuern kämpfte für die
reduktion sämtlicher steuern und die
institutionen die troika bestand darauf
dass wir die steuern erhöhen sollten um
das publikum nicht zu verwirren
ich mag hier mit ihnen philosophisch
über meine marxistischen prägungen
diskutieren über den einfluss von hayek
auf mich und ihnen von keynes und so
weiter aber als es zu diesen
verhandlungen kam spielte das alles
keine rolle
aber warum nicht
das ist eine sehr interessante frage
nicht wahr
lassen sie mich die frage umformulieren
warum wollten die gläubiger ihr geld
nicht zurück das ist die frage
denn hätten sie ihr geld zurück gewollt
hätten sie nicht auf die politik
investiert die letzten sommer
durchgesetzt wurde und nicht dazu zwang
mein amt niederzulegen weil ich nicht
unterschreiben wollte ein einfaches
beispiel dazu unser publikum ihren der
schweiz wird entsetzt sein
sie zwangen die zebras regierung ein
gesetz zu akzeptieren wonach alle
unternehmen von kleinen ein mann betrieb
bis zum großunternehmen ende 2015
im voraus sämtliche steuern zu zahlen
hätten
die aufgrund von schätzungen der
steuerbehörden 2016 anfallen würden
so etwas macht man nicht außer man will
in einem land die wirtschaftlichen
aktivitäten das einkommen und die
steuereinnahmen reduzieren
das ist also die frage man könnte
darüber eine ganze sendung machen die
kurze antwort ist sie waren nicht daran
interessiert griechenland zu reformieren
sie wollten griechenland gar nicht
helfen sich zu erholen sie waren nur
daran interessiert eine regierung zu
fall zu bringen die gewagt hatte nein zu
sagen deshalb weil in portugal spanien
und irland wahlen anstanden
sie wollten nicht dass die menschen in
diesen ländern die botschaft erhalten
dass sie eine regierung wählen können
die nein sagt zur troika und stattdessen
mit verhandlungen ein gutes abkommen
erreicht es handelt sich um reine
machtpolitik im stil des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts die die auflösung von
demokratie und solidarität in europa
stark vorantreibt
ein sehr trauriger tatbestand ich stelle
mich jetzt in die position der anderen
und würde dann vielleicht wirklich ich
probiere es und würde sagen okay wir
wären vielleicht bereit gewesen mit
ihnen als radikal linken
minister aus athen zu reden wenn sie
nicht zuerst gekommen während es gab
diese berühmte pressekonferenz
wir haben zwei drei tage minister erst
saßen neben jerome weißer blumen dem
mann des übrigen europas und haben die
troika rausgeworfen sie haben ein
bisschen blamiert haben gesagt ich habe
niemanden raus geworfen ich interveniere
hier weil das bloß wiederholen von
zerrbildern ist es ist zeit der wahrheit
eine chance zu geben
natürlich war es nicht so gehen sie auf
youtube anhören sie sich an was sich an
der seite von präsident blum gesagt habe
man stellte mir eine frage zur troika
mann fragte mich ob meine regierung und
mein ministerium bereit sein mit der
troika weiterzufahren
ich gab eine sehr wohl überlegte und
moderate antwort ich sagte was ist das
sind die drei institutionen europäische
zentralbank iwf und die eu kommission
griechenland ist mitglied dieser drei
ehrwürdigen institutionen
wir sind seit der bretton woods
konferenz von 1944 mitglied des
währungsfonds
wir waren eines der gründungsmitglieder
von bretton woods und iwf wir sind
mitglied der euro-zone wir wollen dass
sein und wollen es auch in zukunft
bleiben
es ist also klar dass die ezb unsere
zentralbank ist und wir deren mitglied
sind
natürlich sind wir stolz europäer und
ein staat der europäischen union also
ist die europäische kommission unsere
regierung
selbstverständlich werden wir uns mit
dem iwf der kommission und die ezb
auseinandersetzen
selbstverständlich werden wir mit ihnen
verhandeln und voll mit ihnen
zusammenarbeiten aber das ist nicht die
troika sagte ich das wort troika tauchte
2010 auf nachdem wir diesen toxischen
rettungskredit erhalten hatten dem ich
mich damals widersetzte und gegen den
ich auch heute bin deshalb weil sie kein
recht haben geld zu leihen wenn sie
bankrott sind um so zu tun als wären sie
es nicht sie wollten das geld gar nicht
von den deutschen und den handel wenn
sie bankrott sind haben sie eine
moralische verpflichtung so lange
ein weiteres geld aufzunehmen weil es
sie wieder zahlungsfähig sind
aber das ist eine andere geschichte
dieser schreckliche dir mit dem
rettungskredit wurde im mai 2010
abgeschlossen
das war der zeitpunkt als die troika
gebildet wurde
die troika bestand nicht aus den drei
institutionen die troika war eine gruppe
von technokraten aus niedrigen oder
mittleren vertretern dieser drei
institutionen die mit einem großen
flugzeug im flughafen von athen landeten
etwa 30 bis 60 leute die dann in
griechischen ministerien eindrangen und
dort griechische minister gewählte
vertreter des griechischen volkes zur
verantwortung gezogen
das ist ein toxischer prozess was ich in
dieser pressekonferenz neben eisel blum
sagte war
unabhängig davon was ich darüber denke
dieser prozess führte dazu dass
griechenland nicht zu reformieren war
die griechischen bürger verstanden das
als besatzungsarmee als eine
invasionsarmee wo eine minister eines
landes von nicht gewählten gesichtslosen
bürokraten gesagt wird was er zu tun hat
in seinem eigenen ministerium
das kann nicht gutgehen im hinblick
darauf dass die griechische bevölkerung
so ausgehandelte reformen annimmt mein
standpunkt war dass diese troika dieser
prozess erledigt ist und dass ihr
erledigt sein müsse weil europa wissen
sollte was es braucht um ein
reformprogramm für griechenland für
portugal für wen auch immer zu entwerfen
und einen aufsichts prozess ich bin
nicht gegen supervision der nicht
demütigen ist und der ein land nicht
unregierbar macht weil sich die
bevölkerung gegen den ganzen aufsichts
prozess stellt könnte man sagen es war
auch ein akt der nationalen würde der
dazu beigetragen hat dass überhaupt ein
radikales lackes ist das falsch nein
eigentlich frage ob das die motivation
war für viele desiree sah die linken die
radikalen an die macht zu wählen
ja natürlich aber sehen sie die würde
ist etwas das wir griechen franzosen und
spanier den höchst
stellenwert hat der troika prozess ist
äußerst entwürdigen und zudem illegal
sie müssen sich vorstellen er ist
illegal die europäische zentralbank ist
die zentralbank von griechenland die
zentralbank von spanien
warum haben wir zentralbanken geschaffen
in der schweiz in deutschland in den
vereinigten staaten von amerika
die banken offen zu halten auch wenn es
probleme gibt um die banken in
liquiditätskrisen offen zu halten
und jetzt halten sie sich vor augen was
am 30 juni in griechenland passiert ist
die europäische zentralbank schloss die
griechischen banken die sich selber als
solvent deklarierten um unsere regierung
zu zwingen eine abmachung zu
unterschreiben wonach sie 2015 geschäfte
zu besteuern habe die erst 2016 gemacht
werden hätte ich ihnen vor 15 jahren
erzählt dass sich europa eines tages in
solch einer misslichen lage befinden
könnte dass wir so etwas tun würden sie
hätten gesagt ich sei verrückt und doch
haben wir diese situation erreicht es
ist keine nachhaltige situation für die
menschen in griechenland die menschen in
frankreich aber auch für die europäische
zentralbank ist es entwürdigend dass wir
derart in die klemme sind gerade auch in
diesem land hier in der schweiz würden
sie einige sympathie finden sich für
diese überlegungen dass die würde jedes
status respektiert werden muss aber was
tun jetzt es ist doch auch ein gebilde
diese eu die demokratisch entstanden ist
wo die nationalen parlamente eine
komplizierte verpflichtung von
institutionen auf irgendeine weise schon
mal funktioniert wollen sie das
grundsätze wollen sie grundsätzlich raus
wollten sie es grundsätzlich reformieren
nicht im geringsten
ich bin ein überzeugter europäer meine
größte sorge ist dass die regeln die
angewendet werden und ihr mangel an
würde die man den verschiedenen
nationalstaaten entgegenbringt jene
dunklen kräfte stärken die die
europäische union sprengen wollen meine
große befürchtung ist dass wie in den
dreißiger jahren als die großen
europäischen mächte und regierungen weil
sie ihre sehr engen eigeninteressen
verfolgten schließlich europa zerstörten
es in die luft sprengten
dass wir genau im gleichen prozess
stecken die interessen der bürokratie in
brüssel die interessen der ezb
bürokratie in frankfurt das interesse
der deutschen bundesregierung der
griechischen italienischen regierung
wenn all diese interessen unabhängig
voneinander verfolgt werden ohne dialog
und institutionelle rahmenbedingungen
die ein zusammenspiel dieser interessen
ermöglichen werden sie uns auseinander
treiben die einzigen leute und kräfte
die von der momentanen situation
profitieren sind jene kräfte die europa
zerstören wollen
jene die wollen dass frankreich die
eurozone verlässt
großbritannien aus der europäischen
union austritt jene die eine
konstellation anstreben in der berlin
über paris dominiert was zu einer
erstattung von marine le pen wird wie
bei jedem gespräch an dem ich mich als
engagierter europäer beteilige weise ich
auch hier auf eine ganz simple tatsache
hin dass wir einen vernünftigen weg
finden um unsere differenzen zu lösen
wie die schweiz an den rationalen
mechanismus zur lösung von konflikten
hat bis wir soweit sind in europa so
etwas zu schaffen wird diese europäische
union zerfallen
aber sie sind jetzt wieder ein outsider
einer der ice mit scharfen verstand
analysieren kann
wie können die drin sind die noch
minister sind den weg dorthin
so bin ich von außen nicht ich bin ein
europäischer bürger ich bin in europa
ich meine nur nicht mehr
regierungsverantwortung im moment die
sie haben aber sehen sie für die
regierung wissen sie als ich beschloss
mich nicht der wahl fürs parlament zu
stellen begründete ich meine nicht
kandidatur damit dass ich mich auf die
politik konzentrieren wolle
ja wer die frage ist nur sehen sie ein
weg an konkreten weg den die
verantwortungsträger jetzt schon
einschlagen könnten um zu einem in ihrem
sinne demokratischeren europa zu kommen
absolut es gibt möglichkeiten die
technischen schritte die man machen
müsste sind naheliegend absolut legal
sogar im rahmen der bestehenden verträge
die viel zu wünschen übrig lassen
lassen sie mich einige beispiele geben
wir können damit anfangen dass wir viel
größere transparenz bei der
entscheidfindung schaffen
die euro gruppe die alle wichtigen
entscheide fällt die sich auf die
wirtschaft der eurozone auswirken und
damit verbunden auch auf die schweizer
wirtschaft hat keine gesetzliche
grundlage
es wird kein protokoll geführt so werden
die europäischen bürger nie erfahren was
in ihren namen dort tränen gesagt wird
diese meetings sind in der regel schon
vorgespurt durch schatten meetings in
korridoren sollte man sie öffentlich
machen
ich finde ja ich bin der meinung dass
jeder bürger europas das recht hat zu
wissen was sein finanzminister in seinem
namen an diesen meetings sagt seit wann
ist transparenz ein hindernis für einen
demokratischen prozess
es ist genau andersherum das können wir
sofort tun ohne die gesetze zu verändern
oder so etwas
zweitens müssen wir die vier bereiche
identifizieren in denen des integration
stattfindet einer davon ist das problem
der geringen investitionen
wir haben in europa das tiefste
investitionsniveau der letzten 40 jahre
das erstaunt zumal wir gleichzeitig den
höchsten stand an ersparnissen haben
dieses ungleichgewicht sehr viele
ersparnisse sehr wenige investitionen
ist das problem
dann haben wir die krise der
öffentlichen schulden
das resultat geringer ökonomischer
aktivitäten als folge von geringen
investitionen in der gesamten eurozone
haben wir ein ernsthaftes problem mit
unseren banken diese idee dass wir
separate bankensysteme haben und
gleichzeitig eine banken union
proklamieren die es nur dem namen nach
das ist die bankenkrise und wir haben
eine humanitäre krise
zunehmende armut in vielen teilen der
eurozone der europäischen union nicht
nur im süden nicht nur an der peripherie
sondern auch in teilen deutschlands ins
heim die entwickelten länder die durch
ungleiche verteilung nur innerlich
auseinandergerissen werden diese vier
krisen können mit den bestehenden
institutionen angegangen werden
das ist eine philosophische sendungen
wir wollen das publikum nicht langweilen
wir könnten institutionen um nutzen
indem wir die aktuellen abkommen
geschickt neu auslegen als ersten
schritt richtung stabilisierung danach
bräuchten wir an einem gewissen punkt
eine verfassungsgebende versammlung die
eine ganz einfache frage stellt wie
wollen wir uns verbünden
es gibt zwei alternativen in den
nächsten zehn jahren entweder wir werden
eine demokratische föderation oder
europa fällt auseinander
wir haben die wahl in dieser sendung die
ich schon fast zu ihrem ende jetzt kommt
glaube ich haben wir gesehen in dem was
ich dieses griechische drama genannt
habe ein bisschen konzentriert auf den
protagonisten schäuble und den
protagonisten swarovskis über
verschiedene sichten europas und der
demokratie haben ja sicher gesehen dass
wenn man sich genau an hört und liest
was ihre seite sagt dass das mindestens
interessant und sehr diskussionswürdig
ist meine letzte frage ist wenn wir uns
anschauen wie der dialog verlief sie
waren auch ein guter akteur in sachen
medien kommunikation sie haben sich auch
inszeniert aber man kann sagen es ist
kein dialog entstanden
es war eine dialog des taubstummen haben
ja miteinander geredet haben sie ein
bisschen hoffnung dass in diesem europa
ein dialog entstehen kann wo
verschiedene lager und interessen seiten
einen guten weg finden
der grund weshalb wir einen dialog unter
tauben führten war dass die gläubiger
nur unseren zusammenbruch war
sie wollten keinen dialog mit uns wenn
europa so weiterfährt
wenn den schuldnern demokratische rechte
verwehrt werden und man diese als luxus
versteht die den gläubigern vorbehalten
ist dann ist das das ende von europa
übrigens das bild das sie von mir auf
dem motorrad zeigen
ich bin mein ganzes leben lang motorrad
gefahren und werde es weiter tun
ich gebe nicht vor jemand zu sein der
ich nicht bin nur weil das alte
politische spiele so wie ich sage ihnen
als ich ins ministerium einzug fand ich
dort zwei bmws gepanzert totale kosten
750.000 euro ich entledigte mich morgens
fuhr ich von zu hause genauso in mein
büro wie ich zuvor an die universität
gefahren bin oft diesen motor macht man
daraus ein medienspektakel oder nutzt es
als mittel zur kritik an meiner person
führt dass die kritiker die sagen dass
griechische politiker zu viel geld
ausgeben hat absurden glück politischen
spending wir haben gehört sie sind ein
leidenschaftlicher europäer sie sind ein
dialog interessiert sie werden an diesem
dialog weiter teilnehmen wir haben
keinen zweifel daran bedanke mich
herzlich ja nicht sagen
die geldtasche in der sternstunde kunst
sehen sie jetzt gleich einen
dokumentarfilm über den großen
volksschauspieler mathias gnädinger
zuerst aber noch ein kleines
philosophisches gedankenexperiment warum
bleiben wir uns selbst obwohl wir uns
ständig verändern
danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]